while democrats continue to obsessively
smear donald trump uh well biden is
steering this country right off a cliff
here now with moore the author of not my
first rodeo south dakota governor
christie known governor um what's so
frustrating to me and and i know for
example on my radio show of you know i
have 700 stations i'm talking to people
all over the country
is that we could have prevented the
disaster at the border we shouldn't
be aiding and abetting law breaking we
have immigration laws they're not being
upheld as a matter of fact the
administration is offering preferential
treatment for people entering the
country illegally uh we get rid of uh
energy independence something we
achieved the first time in 75 years
shouldn't shock anyone we have a 40-year
41-year inflation high and record high
gas prices all of this to me is
preventable so where do we go from here
considering i don't think this party is
going to change or this president's
going to change
no you're exactly right sean and that's
what is so challenging for the people in
my state and across this country
is we're facing a situation soon where
president biden's approval ratings are
going to be even lower than the
inflation rate
people are really struggling out there
with high energy costs high food costs
they recognize all these illegal
immigrants are coming into the country
that the border's not being enforced
that it's not secure it's jeopardizing
our national security they aren't
talking about what all the other
networks are running today they're
talking about how do we get through the
next
six months until we get a new majority
in the house that stops a lot of these
bad policies how do we make sure that
we're going to be able to meet our
budget how do we make sure that we're
going to continue to thrive and pursue
the american dream here in south dakota
people are doing great we've got
record income increases the last three
years in fact the highest in the nation
our record-setting revenues that are
coming in our economy is booming but
that's just not the story across the
country and with biden attacking our
very way of life uh it's going to be a
full-time job for everybody to try to
protect our way of life
i'm looking at every big city and in
most cities that have been run by
liberal democrats most states deep blue
run by liberal democrats for decades and
you see
from 2020 to 2021 and now
continuing into 2022 record murder rapes
crime larceny you name it and it seems
like
like the chaos is being won over you
know defunding dismantling nobel has not
worked out well for these cities where
is the person on the democratic side
that says you know what
maybe it sounded good on paper but it's
not working out reality and innocent
people are getting hurt and we need to
protect the people in our state and our
city and our town
yeah they're not having an honest
conversation are they especially when
president biden ran on being a unifier
they've done the exact opposite it's
gotten worse and democrat-run cities
across the country that's why they're
moving to our state we have the second
highest inbound migration in the country
i mean i know south dakota is beautiful
and our people are fantastic but that's
the first time we've seen that kind of
peop of movement of people picking up
from california new york city detroit
chicago they're coming to south dakota
because they want to live somewhere
where the leaders respect the law
governor you want to make sure
and raise them don't let them bring
their bad politics with them if they're
going to move to another state to escape
the the
horrific taxes and regulation and high
crime uh let's hope they change their
political affiliation in some cases but
you're making a good point there is a
migration towards tennessee the
carolinas
south dakota and away from big cities
new york new jersey illinois chicago la
san francisco people leaving in droves
on the people that are coming they're
registering to vote right away and
they're registering republican
so they want to be somewhere the
government respects them that should be
a clear message to joe biden be a clear
message to these democrats that are
trying to distract from what's really
happening across this country from joe
biden's inflation
all right now my first rodeo uh the new
book governor christine ohm gnome it's
on amazon.com bookstores everywhere
governor great to have you thank you for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else